earlier that we would show you show you
how to analyze the gene expression data
from an RNA seek pipeline and here we're
going to examine that normalized data
that you generated while you're going
through the PCA platform up go through
the PCA pipeline not the the data
straight out of the RNA our pipeline go
up here file import
normalized data
and one big issue you're going to note
is that the samples are mixed up
together so you have your your er
samples and your TN samples all mixed up
so you're going to want to distribute
them like cut and paste and against with
their group together it's gonna make the
analysis a lot easier for you now we go
data I've already done this and I'm not
wasting your time shuffling them about
we're going to go to the end that's
right t-test up here and fold yeah
so they want to analyze our T tests and
go to where all those some is go down to
more functions and we're going to search
t-test there and we have our first array
so once you get them properly organized
write down the the ranges of the array
I've already done this so it's B 2 2 n 2
0:02
to you too
and it's two-tailed test and because we
have unequal variance here we're gonna
use type three this all explained in the
in the course and the lesson done so we
get a we have a t-test value of zero
point zero seven not significantly
different we're using 0.05 as our our
alpha value to demonstrate significance
and then if you double click that it'll
fill up all the rest of the cells and
then we want to get kept with full
difference so we type average so we want
to take the average of the first range
the average of the second range there's
two ways we can pretty much
analyze this so again we want to have a
t-test piece p-value of less than 0.05
and so here we would just hit filter
I'll see where that we have a filter
and drop that down and we want to be
less than or equal to 0.05 and we'll
filter out those that as you can see it
changed that have a p-value of less than
or equal to 0.05 and then we're also
interested in having a full difference
of greater than or equal to two so
greater than or equal to 2 or less than
or equal to negative 2 and so we're at
our filter there and we want to choose
greater than or equal to 2 or less than
or equal to negative 2 and that what
that's what we see here and you can see
over here on the Left these are the rows
of genes that have greater for that that
meet these two requirements and so we
see that we have a subset of it and so
that's how you would analyze these
results using traditional methods